[Music]
please welcome
our first speaker ellis hughes sorry
computer went to sleep
did i type it right yes all right thank
you all for being here today i
appreciate you coming to
this talk so how many of you have
written a package before
all right how many of you have been
participating participated in a
validation
oh less hands how many of you have
validated in our package
ah awesome all right so the end of the
talk today
hopefully you will now have some steps
that you can follow to validate your r
packages
so before we get going what is computer
system validation
so that is establishing documentary
evidence that our software performs some
sort of task
activity process in compliance with the
specification we've laid out
with a high degree of assurance so
there's a couple very important aspects
to that it's documenting the evidence
and then it's compliance with the
specifications with a high degree of
assurance so you're fairly solid you are
sure that it'll continue to behave the
way you expect it to
so the part of the reason that we do
validation is it's required for fda
submission
uh there's the 21 or 21 cfr 11
and there's also some general principles
of software validation that was released
by the fda in 2002
giving us some guidelines to how we
should be performing our validations
but that isn't the only reason we should
be doing validation validation has a lot
of other benefits as well
such as improved quality and safety with
the products that we generate
it results in faster processing because
we already have a system in place
and it promotes trust with our outputs
because we've already tested it in a
variety of a variety of inputs so we
already know
that it's going to produce like good
results or it'll error out if it doesn't
validation is very different from
verification and often they're confused
so we're going to go over that a little
bit too
so their validation is does the system
behave as we expect it to
will it return the correct value given
the input or will it throw an error if
the values are outside of our
expectations
verification on the other hand is simply
do two separate processes
on the same data set for example give us
the same output
so it's similar but different and so
that'll frame what we're talking about
today
but for small companies validation can
be a high bar
there's a lot of labor hours in
validation and there's tracking the
progress there's
writing everything around that and
tracking the documentation
which can feel like a lot of work you're
constantly filling out
this paperwork that's outside of your
coding for
for validation it feels a little
excessive because you first have to
develop and get signed off on your
specifications
next you're gonna have to write the
actual code following good programming
practices and record who wrote the which
functions
then you have to document and develop
your test cases and get sign off on that
next write your test code based on your
test cases and record who wrote that
manually evaluate and document the test
code results
once again getting a third party to do
that and finally review all this
documentation that you have and get
final sign off for release that's a lot
of work there's a lot of different parts
of validation and at any point it can
feel like game over
you just have to restart and redo the
whole process over again
but i'm here to tell you that validation
and r
can be best friends they can work
together to create an awesome product
using our markdown test that and oxygen
2
we can create pdfs that look like this
within our
packages that track who wrote the
specifications who wrote the functions
the test who wrote the test cases and
test code capture our specifications as
we wrote them and the test cases
within the pdf and finally display all
the test results surrounding that so my
name is ellis hughes i'm a statistical
programmer
i have a history working in statistical
genetics and currently i work in hiv
vaccine research
i'm also really involved with the
community i'm a seattle usr organizer
and this past year i helped run the
cascadia r conference which was really
rewarding
uh fred hutch uh is known for cancer
research but they also do vaccine
development
and that's the team that i are the group
that i work with and it's called sharp
we were established in 1992 and we've
had a worldwide impact on hiv and aids
vaccine research so here's the
the five steps that i would say are part
of validation first you have to have
your
you have your specifications then you
write the code then you write your test
cases
then you write the actual test case code
and finally you document it all together
i'm also assuming that you're going to
be writing a package for this validation
so here's a sample of what a generic
package might look like
so first when you're when you're working
on your specifications
you're trying to lay out what are the
requirements of your package what will
the package do
what are the expected outputs of your of
your package and what are the high level
steps that are going to be followed so
this isn't going into detail this is
laying out the groundwork for everything
so if i were to be writing a
specification for my presentation today
i'd say the contents of my my
presentation will cover my team's
approach to validation
it'll be roughly 15 to 20 minutes long
and hopefully it'll be entertaining
so when i go to record this these
specifications
i i'm going to want to use our markdown
to document all this for me
i'm going to use a single file per
specification and number those
specifications
within it in addition i'm going to use
roxygen2
to add details around who wrote that
specification and when
and what the specification title is and
then i'm going to put this inside my r
package
so these are the same specifications
that i had earlier
but now it's written in markdown i have
details surrounding
what the what the specification is and
that i wrote it and i wrote it yesterday
i i'm also will explain what the
validation procedure
be 15 to 20 minutes long and hopefully
be entertaining
fame and glamour might follow later who
knows all right so
the the benefit of putting our
specifications within our package and
writing it in our markdown
it allows us to really quickly update
the specifications if any of them change
additionally we can change the ownership
if somebody goes and updates
the specifications they are already
right there for them to update
it by putting it inside the package it's
close to the the task at hand so it's
really easy to reference you don't have
to find a third-party document
to pull that information in and it also
by separating out the specifications in
their own files it forces you to
decouple your specifications so they're
not reliant on one another
so you can make very clear
specifications
these these specification or markdown
files
we suggest putting them under the
vignettes folder creating a validation
folder
and finally creating a folder for all
your specifications and dropping all of
them in there
now your code now you might be thinking
this right now
and don't worry i'm not here to tell you
actually how to code
i'm simply going to talk about how you
want to document this code when you're
writing it for validation
so typically when you're documenting the
code ownership you're going to be using
an external resource
such as word excel maybe smartsheets and
this is really cumbersome because it's
outside of your programming world
you have to take a minute and step out
of it and go and record oh
i updated this function on this date and
here's what happened
and that's that really just takes you
out of their flow of programming
what i suggest doing is using the
section tag and
oxygen and documenting the last updated
by
and the last updated date so you can
record
who updated it and when and it's right
there within the function you can also
do it at function creation
the the benefit of using these oxygen
tags is it doesn't alter how it would
behave when you're trying to compile
your manuals
and actually has added benefit of
recording it in the manual
who wrote the function and when they
last updated it so you can track that
but now somebody came in and they
updated my function they changed they
changed how long the function is going
to wait
and so this was not done by me and it
was done today
but it is right there in the code they
didn't have to step outside and remember
to update it in the smartsheet or the
excel file
it's able to do it right there within
the function and
in the commit it's tracked if you're
using version control
so when you compile it and build your
your functions it doesn't look
any different you can write your test as
well it's going to behave exactly the
same as it normally would but now you
have this tracker
embedded into your code now when you're
writing your test cases so test cases
are where you're actually going to draw
the connection between the code that you
wrote
and the the actual specifications that
you have and how to pair them together
so these are distinct from unit tests
they're often confounded with one
are confused with one another but unit
tests are for testing as the function
author
does your function behave the way you're
expecting it to
test cases on the other hand are for
documenting how you've
matched up with your specifications
similar but different
a single test case can satisfy multiple
specifications
conversely a single specif but a single
specification must match
to at least one test case so you have to
prove that each specification has been
met
so the way you go through and document
your test cases is first you record
which specification is going to be met
specify the required input data for your
test case
record the steps you need to be
following but
without writing any code then detail the
expectations
that they'll need to be testing to prove
that you've met these specifications
you'll use our markdown to perform this
task and you'll use oxygen 2
to document all that additional
information such as who wrote that test
case
and when so this is what a test case
might look like once again for my
presentation
i would first see that i met my
specifications by gathering a captive
audience of co-workers and probably
later my significant other
ask them give them the presentation and
ask them
if it was informative ask them what they
learned i can then type my presentation
to see if i was actually
between the 15 and 20 minutes and then i
can see if i was entertaining
by the number of eye rolls from my
significant other or chuckles from my
coworkers
by the modular test case or using this
modular test case
format it makes it easy to shift and
update your test cases so you can
as as you get more information you can
change them or make sure that you're
hitting all the specifications
these will also live under the
validation folder you created but create
a new folder called test
yeah test cases now test case coding
this is where you actually implement the
new test cases that you just wrote
in our markdown you're going to record
the results
um of those of those test cases and then
you're going to have a third party
write this code it's critical to have
this third party do it because they have
no prior knowledge
of the function the way the function
should be behaving
the benefits of this is it reduces or it
helps resolve any interpretation errors
before you release it
they're able to go through your
documentation because they don't know
the way that it's supposed to behave
and see if there's any uncle and
anything that's unclear about
your arguments the way you set that up
additionally they'll be going through
your test cases
and seeing how that works and if there's
any questions
or if there's any ambiguity in the way
that they're supposed to be processing
it
they come back and ask you and they can
improve your test cases and prove your
code
and they can also potentially identify
any places for improvements in your
code itself they could have a
preconceived notion with the way how
quickly things should be running
and by going through it and if it runs
slower they can bring that up to you and
you can go back and update it
so the approach that we're going to take
with uh these this test code is
we're going to use a familiar format
called test flat i think most people
that have developed a hack to know that
we're also going to augment these test
cases
with oxygen 2. i don't know if you've
noticed but there's a bit of a theme
so this looks like any other test
test case that you might your test that
you might run normally but we've added
this oxygen documentation
about who what the test is who wrote
that test
and when they wrote it so it was not
done by me so it's a third party
they did it today and they wrote out all
the
expectations that they were supposed to
be doing so in this case the test case
was rather simple they were just putting
in a simple function
and seeing what it returned but this is
this is a simplification of the idea
that can be generally applicable
we're using test that because it's a
familiar framework most people if
they've written a package before
already know how to write tests using
test that they can
develop their test code interactively
meaning they don't have to just send it
off to batch
and have it run and see what the results
are but it does allow for automation so
we can actually execute
all of the test cases at once within a
file and capture that
all that information what's called a
reporter object so these are objects
output by test lat
and they help they track each test and
expectations
it will report a success with if each
expectation
passes and it will report failure and
for each one of the expectations you
have track all that as well
the benefit is also that we can easily
access the contents
so this is a standard output of a
reporter object that you're probably
familiar with if you're building tests
and do control shift t in your rstudio
ide
it'll output that and you could do that
if that's acceptable by your
organization
but we were required to actually make a
nice printed output
of a table where we're recording each of
our expectations and whether they were
as expected or it'll report the failure
mode and then additionally a pass
fail surrounding that by writing a test
code additionally in this modular format
it makes it so that we can update
the test code and track who updated that
when independently so if somebody works
on a function
and but they can they can then still do
test code development for
functions that they haven't worked on
yet these will live within the
validation folder
uh as i said earlier this time under
test code and
number them from however many test cases
you have all right
so the final document the what we're
going to be presenting at the very end
is so what do we have so far we first
have the documents
written in markdown for the
specifications next we have
oxygen documentation and all our code
that records who wrote what
we have documents in our tests excuse me
we have our test cases
written markdown that we can scrape that
as well and we have our test case
code that is written in test flat
augmented with oxygen documentation
so you can use oxygen 2 to scrape all
the lists of ownership from all of all
of our various
locations we have our markdown so we can
pull that out of the files
and print that out nicely and we can use
that to generate our final document
finally we have test that that records
all the results of the code
and we can then print that into a nice
table so with their powers combined
we can generate that pdf that i showed
you earlier but now you have some
reference
and each of the specifications and all
the documents that i showed you earlier
were used to compile this pdf
where i wrote the specifications and uh
but i did not write the most recent
version of that function
additionally the specifications of what
my presentation must be
and what the what i was going to be
testing and the expectations the very
end are all documented there so you can
grow this as
as many tests as you need to to pass all
your specifications
so this is what the final file format
might look like it doesn't look
any different than another r package but
it has this ability to have validation
stored within it and makes it very
simple for you to validate
it makes this the process very simple so
validation and r can truly live together
forever
so i'd like to take a second to thank my
team back at fred hutch for helping me
work and develop this idea
and this presentation thank my wife for
listening to me give this presentation a
number of times
um this this presentation is available
at thebioengineer.github.com
validation the html behind
all of the slides as well as a sample
package lives on my github
validation and then you can find me on
twitter thank you
[Music]
awesome job alice we do have a couple
questions here for you and we have five
minutes so let's go ahead and tackle
these
um it's the first one is how does
version control eg get
fit into validation is that a viable
alternative to tags inside the code
itself um so that depends on your org's
take on version control and how they
want to approach that
this makes it so that we can track this
outside of version control
and makes makes it independent of any of
that so
it i mean potentially if your org would
allow that but
it's all dependent on your org fantastic
question two
how do these methods of validating
internal packages compare and contrast
with how you validate
external packages um
well i guess that would be once again
depending on your org how you want to
approach that
so i mean eventually it would be really
cool is if we get all packages to start
doing this approach
especially if we're going to use it in
pharma where we can have this document
of truth going this is what i tested
here's what i was testing against
and here's what the results were also
add there's a the r validation hub
that's looking at at that challenge
um the third question here is how long
um
oh let me see oh here's another one um
ever looked at how like
ci or cd tools could fit into this
workflow oh i definitely
think there's an opportunity to use that
as part of your build
process where you can have it build this
pro or this validation tool for you
uh what i didn't go into is the idea
that we would then print out this pdf at
the end of the day
have people sign manually sign off
because we don't have
e-cigs yet and we can then have a final
word document that's like this is
this is truth we've signed off on this
manually
in wet inc but it was generated
automatically for us
awesome awesome i got two uh last
questions here we'll tackle real quick
uh the first one how do you document
code testing coverage design
um so there's several tools in r to
do that in generic test cases but with
these
these uh test cases here we're
documenting we don't necessarily have a
direct way to test that that would be
definitely a good feature to be adding
is tracking which specifications were
being met by which so you could create a
matrix so that's definitely a good idea
awesome well thank you ellis it was
great talk thank you